the homeless crisis is literally a scam
no one wants to fix it
why because homelessness is a business
is that a very small group of people are
making a lot of money off of
let me explain so you're the head of an
organization that's tasked with solving
homelessness in a place like New York
City
maybe you operate homeless shelters
maybe you're the one building homeless
shelters maybe you prepare and hand out
food to the homeless whatever it is you
are a generous Noble person doing God's
work and you have your work cut out for
you there are around a hundred thousand
homeless people in New York City right
now including children so if you're
gonna solve this homelessness crisis
each of those 100 000 people are gonna
need food water heating a place to live
job training to get them working again
and that's gonna cost a lot of money
luckily the city of New York cash your
back
the city gets a 2.6 billion dollar slush
fund every single year to solve this
homelessness problem 2.6 billion dollars
for a hundred thousand people think
about how much money that is that breaks
down to 26 000 for every single homeless
person on the streets of New York right
now
on top of that New York City has over
350
000 vegan units Eunice no one lives in
maybe they need a little bit of a
touch-up but 350 000 units just waiting
to be occupied
hmm 350 000 vacant units 100 000
homeless 26 000 per homeless person
whether a 350 000 vacant units a hundred
thousand homeless people wait what if we
just
oh I know why don't we just whoa whoa
not so fast our Mother Teresa let's not
jump to any Hasty conclusions now shall
we think about it if we just solve the
homelessness problem just like that
there would be no need for a 2.4 billion
dollar slush fund which means we will
stop getting 10 million dollar contracts
350 million dollar contracts we would
have to stop paying ourselves million
dollar salaries well we can't let that
happen now can we so what would any
rational human being do in this
predicament where you're making a
literal Fortune solving homelessness but
if you solved homelessness you would
stop making a fortune oh you would solve
the homelessness problem as fast as
possible because it's the right thing to
do and you don't want to waste taxpayers
dollars
yeah right no you would do your best to
stretch out this crisis as long as
possible because as long as there are
homeless in the streets there is money
to be made so give the homeless the bare
minimum slap together a peanut butter
sandwich throw it in a bag hand it to
them and then charge the city a kidney
for it see on the outside you want to
act like a Saints a saint that never
quite has enough money to accomplish her
Mission while in the background you
quietly siphon as much money out of this
homelessness business as possible this
is the reality that everyone is afraid
to say out loud it's why even with this
giant budget homelessness in New York
City is at the highest levels it's ever
been since the Great Depression with
almost double the amount of homeless
people compared to 10 years ago
homelessness is a rackets and if you're
going to participate in this racket you
better play it right subscribe for more
and welcome to the homelessness
industrial complex and the more money
that the government
we were getting
if you want to make more money if you're
looking to make big moves then you gotta
have a good bird's eye view of what's
happening in this crazy ever-changing
world the problem is reading or watching
Financial or economic news is time
consuming and very hard to understand
that is why you gotta check out the
daily upside and this is free too so
you're going to want to stick around the
daily upside is this awesome free
newsletter that condenses all the
business economics and investing news
out there and serves it to you on a
silver platter via super short sweet
newsletter straight into your inbox
every single day it has over 750 000
subscribers and was founded by a group
of financial professionals every email
starts off with a short paragraph or two
then a few of the most important bullet
points you need to know for the day and
if any of those bullet points interests
you simply scroll down and read the
super quick summaries on each of those
stories and then boom you just got a
great burst eye view of the most
important things happening in the world
right now so you can make more educated
business and investing decisions in just
a few minutes I personally love getting
my news from the daily upside every day
and sometimes those stories even Inspire
some of my video ideas let the 100
million dollar Deli video and signing up
as free and takes less than 10 seconds
simply pause the video right now click
the link below type in your email and
you are sets you literally have nothing
to lose and you'll be supporting this
channel so pause the video and click the
link below now thanks to the Daily
upside for sponsoring this video
step one in profiting off of the
homelessness crisis is to become friends
with the most powerful people in your
city the mayor the head of the city
council whoever is running your city
find a way to turn them into your close
friend this is because there are only so
many homelessness contracts the city can
dish out and these Power Players hold a
lot of sway over who gets these
lucrative contracts and they are well
aware of just how profitable these
contracts are they're looking for
someone that understands the game as
they do someone that they can depend on
to throw some of that Homeless money
their way once you get your greasy
little hands on it so scheme your way
into their circles visit the same party
system make a generous donation to their
Foundation they're bound to have one buy
them a few thoughtful gifts whatever you
gotta do but you want to know the best
way to get them into your pocket the
best way to become successful in life in
general get these powerful people to owe
you a favor go out of your way to find
out what they're dying for maybe their
kid is a favorite YouTuber that they're
dying to talk to maybe you can pay that
YouTuber to send the kid a personal
selfie video get creative here it
doesn't have to be big but something so
touching yet so out of the blue that
your target will just be begging you to
tell them what they can do to return the
favor once you have that you're golden
Step 2 create an organization that's
supposed to support homeless people it
could be whatever you want a
construction company that's building
shelters a food production company
that's bringing healthy meals to the
streets running your own shelter it
doesn't matter all that matters is that
on paper you and your organization are
fighting for a better life for the
homeless
[Music]
step three now it's time to go back to
that powerful man in office and call in
that favor
you know that new 10 million dollar
contract that 100 million dollar
contract to help in the war against
homelessness why don't you toss it my
way if you played your cards right he
will undoubtedly say yes who else would
he give it to some other schmuck that he
doesn't know or you his friend and Ally
government contracts at the local level
like this almost always go to the
friends and family of the politician or
bureaucrat in charge because why not
friends help out other friends
especially if your friends can give you
a little side action after they get the
contract
foreign
step 4 overcharge once the contract is
within your grasp tell them that now is
not the time to be stingy if they care
about the homeless as much as they say
they should wire you tens of millions of
dollars at the very least how else are
you supposed to fix this huge crisis if
your contract is to house ten thousand
homeless in a shelter and you estimate
that it costs ten thousand dollars for
each person that's already a 100 million
dollar contract No One's Gonna look into
the numbers no Schmucker getting paid
nothing working for the government is
going to look into the economics of
homelessness shelters to make sure your
quote is reasonable so whatever number
you say within reason will look
reasonable
this is the same reason as to why San
Francisco can get away with building a
1.7 million dollar toilet that would
take more than two years to build
quote the former San Francisco
supervisor said the recreation and parks
department told him the going rate for
one public bathroom was 1.7 million
dollars so he secured the full amount
not questioning the price tag end quote
quote they told me 1.7 million dollars
and I got 1.7 million dollars end quote
this was a quote from the assembly
member himself
so make up a giant number and don't
settle for anything less
[Music]
step five now that the money's in your
account you kinda have to start doing
something to help some homeless people
if you don't have anything to show for
all those Millions people would catch on
to your scheme too quickly and it will
become this whole Scandal you don't want
that
so you're gonna have to get to work but
not so fast the only way we're gonna
make any money is if we do the bare
minimum and pocket the difference so
only do the bare minimum that you were
contracted to do remember the longer we
drag on this problem the more contracts
we're going to get awarded so instead of
building Clean safe low-cost housing you
build death trap shelters no homeless
person would ever willingly live in take
this case for example back in 2019 New
York's Department of homeless Services
was about to close on a new deal worth
up to 45 million dollars with help USA
45 million dollars that's a lot of money
the deal to continue operating the wards
Island shelters this shelter housed 233
beds for men sounds pretty reasonable
the reality this shelter is plagued with
black mold rotten pipes no air
conditioning storing heat during summer
rotten food prison style beds
but because they're doing such a great
job help USA was now asking for another
45 million dollars for it I mean come on
the organization is called Help USA it
sounds so Rosy and makes you feel all
fuzzy inside who runs this prestigious
organization you ask why it was founded
by none other than former New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo and is overseen by
his sister Maria Cuomo Cole
what a coincidence and once you've done
the bare minimum now it's time for the
moment you've all been waiting for
[Music]
step six siphon out that catch there are
many ways to go about this so feel free
to get creative you can hand out
contracts to build shelters or food
banks to other businesses that you
happen to own and make an insane amount
of profit over charging for your
services
you can hire your friends and family and
give them a royal salary put your
politicians friends and family on
payroll to send some money back to them
put yourself on a fat cell you can even
use it to pay for exclusive gym
memberships for your entire organization
because you know it's very mentally
taxing to interact with so many poor
disgusting homeless people all day you
gotta sweat off all that poverty in the
sauna and Equinox it's to improve the
mental health of your employees after
all take Denise Perry for example during
the mid-2010s New York paid her
non-profit in the Bronx more than 10
million dollars to provide shelter and
food to families in need but where did
the non-profit's executive director
Denise Perry spend all that money her
gym membership car payments and shopping
sprees at luxury Brands like Tiffany's
in total she took over 2.3 million
dollars from her organization to cover
her exploding credit card bills you
can't help others if you're not looking
after yourself remember
but why stop there why not buy yourself
a nice sports card use as a company car
or use some of the money to build a
completely new business from scratch as
long as you can somehow connect your
purchases with serving the homeless all
bets are off you can even host expensive
lavish parties with only the best bottle
service and DJs as a fundraiser to raise
Global awareness of the homelessness
situation the possibilities are truly
endless and Jack Brown was a master at
this game he's the CEO of core Services
Group a non-profit organization
operating homeless shelters
since 2017 his organization received a
psychotic 352 million dollars in funding
making it the highest paid shelter
operator in New York City and what did
Jack Brown do with all that money he
started his own security company that he
hired to work in his shelters he founded
a maintenance company that made all
kinds of repair work in these shelters
and then there's flavor Foods his own
catering company that fed the people in
the shelters so he was wiring all the
money to his own for-profit companies
while collecting a nice cut from all
those deals his salary over one million
dollars a year not bad for someone who's
leading a non-profit organization he
also hired his relatives for high-paying
positions like his mother and brother
who earned sweet six-figure salaries all
in the name of solving that pesky
homeless problem and here's the kicker
his companies didn't even do their job
for one brown security guards slept on
the job when people started beating each
other up and taking drugs they simply
looked the other way Brown's maintenance
company did nothing about the black mold
in his shelters and homeless people kept
complaining that they were being fed
moldy bacon powdered eggs and
undercooked meat which make them sick on
a daily basis but what do you do when
you're facing nasty allegations like
this you simply deny it Mr Brown wrote
to City officials quote I am proud of
what core achieved end quote but while
he was enjoying the Glamorous Life of a
successful entrepreneur the people in
his shelters were living in a different
kind of hell and with every new round of
funding you simply rinse and repeat the
process and voila you now have the
perfect business you get millions of
dollars served on a silver platter no
one looks into your books as long as you
don't get too wild with them you look
like a philanthropic Saint and you don't
have to do any actual hard work
homelessness may be a racket but it's
nothing compared to the horrors of one
of China's lucrative Industries forced
organ harvesting where the Chinese
military and hospitals forcefully
harvest the organs of prisoners
why because of money of course we're
talking 62 000 for a kidney thirty
thousand dollars for an eye 120
000 for a liver three hundred thousand
dollars for a pair of lungs multiply
that by the ninety thousand transplants
China was processing a year and you get
a number in the billions unfortunately
this is way too graphic to go over in a
public video so we've just released a
private documentary on the subject
available right now only to members of
this Channel and fair warning this is
our most disturbing private documentary
yet all you have to do to watch it is
pause the video scroll down and click
that join button below this YouTube
membership is where we get to post
documentaries every month that we've
wanted to make but couldn't and members
love them and there's a 30-day refund
policy too if it's your first time
joining so you have nothing to lose and
members rarely request a refund anyways
because it's just that worth it pause
the video scroll down and click that
join button now
are you surprised that there is such
thing as a homelessness industrial
complex I personally am not what's up
guys if you're new here my name is Jake
and this is one of the biggest channels
on YouTube for documentaries on money
power war and crime just like this video
so if you enjoyed this one click that
subscribe button below but yeah that's
going to wrap it up thanks for being
part of the Washington and Club stay
dangerous out there and I will see you
guys in the next one